con la Inteligencia artificial está
llegando con fuerza muchos sectores que
se teme exactamente desde el sector de
guionistas que piden concretamente en
este punto
Bueno por primera parte estamos muy
preocupados porque pueden utilizar este
este el chat gpt como manera de
reescribir guiones a contar nuevas
historias de los reemplazar todo el
sistema que para nosotros es esencial
para poder tener una carrera profesional
como guionista en Hollywood y brindarles
el entretenimiento a un mundo que más
que nunca está consumiendo a nuestras
historias de de aquí de Los Ángeles de
Hollywood
se habla también de un aumento de los
salarios en una industria que mueve
miles de millones de dólares al año qué
se pide exactamente en este punto y
desde cuándo no se han producido
aumentos Bueno ya llevamos casi como 10
15 años que no recibimos aumentos de
hecho ya ganamos como el 40% menos que
hace 10 años Mientras tanto Pues los
jefes de todas esas industrias como de
Warner Brothers está ganando 250
millones de dólares al año nosotros en
conjunto como gremios somos once mil
escritores guionistas y todo lo que
pedimos son este pues este aumentos
básicos para poder tener una vida
profesional como guionista que solamente
se acumula con un total de 425 millones
de dólares que Comparado lo que ganan
estas gentes estos jefes de estos este
grandes corporativos realmente no es
nada entonces solamente tenemos pedimos
el derecho de tener una vida profesional
y poder mantener nuestras carreras como
guionistas bueno hablado usted de Los
sueldos de Los grandes de las grandes
figuras de la industria y las
productoras escudan en pérdidas y en la
fuerza de las plataformas de streaming
que aprietan a sus productoras pero las
grandes estrellas como usted dice siguen
ganando millones falta dinero o
redistribución del mismo y han sentido
apoyo de actores o presentadores de la
industria de hecho creo que esto ahí No
necesariamente las estrellas porque
estamos a favor de los de las
celebridades del talento de todo el
mundo de los creadores que forman parte
del entretenimiento Pero estamos
hablando de los ejecutivos o sea los los
que están en estos este corporativos que
se están dando unos saldos unos enormes
en una en una ventana de crisis o sea
están dándose ellos aumentos pero para
todo están reduciendo
los aumentos de los escritores del
talento y recientemente ha habido un
montón de bajas y de despidos a nivel
entre todos los estudios de miles y
miles de ejecutivos que han perdido sus
trabajos porque por las decisiones
erróneas de este mismo liderazgo
corporativo y que podrían o qué pedirían
ustedes para que esta huelga ahora mismo
cese porque puntos principales
empezarían y que necesitaría la
industria para dar un salto cualitativo
en cuanto a la calidad del trabajo pero
como también dice Para que no haya estos
despidos que se han producido en los
últimos tiempos
pues este la herramienta estamos
pidiendo el 2% de las ganancias de todos
estos corporativos que realmente no es
mucho en el en el gran sistema de miles
de miles de millones de dólares es
solamente un pequeño un pequeño Cachito
para poder nosotros avanzar
como como sindicato como gremio para
poder tener una vida una profesional
como guionista y seguir trabajando en
las cosas que nos encantan
entretenimiento las historias en las
series de televisión las películas
nosotros nos encanta nuestro trabajo y
queremos seguir haciéndolo pero no lo
podemos hacer si cada año y cada año
este no ganamos lo que necesitamos para
tener una vida y ahora tenemos La
amenaza de la de la Inteligencia
artificial como reemplazo del trabajo y
la mágica que de la magia que nosotros
producimos en la página